The y intercepts would be 0 comma 3 and 0 comma negative 3. Great work if you
got those two correct. We know for y intercepts we need to let x equal 0. So we
set the value for x equal to 0, and then we solve for y. 0 squared is simply 0,
so this fraction with the 0 in the numerator simplifies to 0. Then we'll just
have the rest of our equation. Y squared divided 9 equals 1. We'll multiply
both sides of the equation by 9 to get y squared equals 9. And then we'll take
the square root of both sides using plus or minus to get 1 y is equal to plus
or minus 3. Notice that we had a y squared term. This led us to have two
solutions for y. We'll have positive 3 and negative 3. We use positive 3 for
one of the y-coordinates, and negative 3 for the other y-coordinate. The
x-coordinates are both 0.